Merci, monsieur le président.
Vous ne prenez pas la parole sur ce débat,
ne prenez pas mon temps de parole, cher président.
Et vous êtes toujours à 0.
On va dépenser aujourd'hui vingt-et-un milliards,
1 peu plus de vingt-et-un milliards,
soit quasiment le budget de la sécurité en France,
comme toujours, en très peu de temps.
Après, ça passera, on va vite, 1 lundi à
à l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est 1 contribution nette
qui est en très forte augmentation depuis des années.
Il y a 1 p'tit creux cette année,
mais qu'il y a des motifs conjonctuels,
euh, 1 net entre 5 et 10 milliards selon les années.
Tout ça pour financer nos concurrents,
alimenter délocalisation de nos industries,
pour mettre en place 1 politique énergétique suicidaire,
pour financer 1 facilité européenne dite de paix
qui n'est que l'alimentation de la guerre,
pour acheter du matériel américain,
pour financer 1 bureaucratie
qui donne des leçons de rigueur à tout le monde
mais qui augmente ses salaires de manière considérable.
Alors euh. Moi
je ne vois pas pourquoi
on prive les français de tant d'argent.
On leur demande tant d'efforts
et on gaspille
cet argent pour 1 politique contraire
fondamentalement à nos intérêts.
Mais il y a pire,
euh. C'est que dans votre rapport, euh.
Vous faites croire que, euh.
Ça va s'améliorer,
mais au sommet de décision du plan de relance,
y a pas eu d'accord sur les ressources propres
et à la fin,
c'est la France qui va payer le Plan de relance ?
Parce que s'il y a pas eu d'accord au moment où on
attribuait les crédits,
je vois pas pourquoi il y en aurait
quand on les attribue plus, euh.
Et la France va payer 66 milliards sans les intérêts
puisque depuis y a 1 augmentation des tonnes d'intérêt
pour recevoir 40 milliards sous condition
pour être en laisse.
On l'a vu au moment euh. De la réforme des retraites.
Donc ça veut bien dire que
le plan de relance
est est 1 très très mauvaise affaire pour notre pays.
J'ajoute que le rabais,
on s'est fait complètement avoir
puisqu'on paye plus de rabais
après le départ des Britanniques qu'avant
et que les autres ont su se protéger.
Euh bref, euh. Quand on regarde le bilan global,
euh. On ne peut être qu'effrayé.
Et puis euh. J'entends les arguments
du président et beaucoup d'entre vous,
il faut être bonne européen,
donc on va voter,
on va voter,
et chaque année d'ailleurs j'entends les mêmes,
mais c'est curieux,
y a plein de pays qui sont bons européens
et qui ne votent pas parfois ce budget qui le négocie ?
Aprement quand je regarde
les contributeurs et les bénéficiaires,
vous pouvez tous trouver sur 1 site internet
de l'Union européenne.
Bien je vois que la France et le dindon de la farce, euh.
Qu'elle paye considérablement
alors qu'elle souffre extrêmement
et puis que beaucoup de pays accumulent des milliards
à nos détriments.
Donc euh. Plutôt que d'embêter les français,
alors augmenter.
Leurs impôts de manière déguisée.
On ferait mieux de réduire cette participation,
merci même de la supprimer.
Merci monsieur,
monsieur dupognon.